hey guys welcome to Thursday's stream
I'm Sam
I'm Michael hi um I cut you off my bad
rude and we're here we're gonna be
playing the new car
battle royale mode in h1z1 yep it's
called Auto royale came out yesterday we
did a quick story on it I actually
played this before it released but we're
here to show it off to y'all
whoo so I'm not gonna lie my first
impressions is it's kind of a gimmick
what is this mode yeah well we all know
that player numbers drop dramatically in
age from zero and especially after pub G
happened mm-hmm and that's my first
assumption is like they they found a
cool fun way to get people to play again
yeah I mean well you got to do something
right it's not terrible it's not
terrible so I'm gonna switch into oh and
hello everybody Oh welcome
sup y'all thanks for joining us and I'm
gonna switch to the gameplay
so because we just entered a match oh
okay well let me tell you all a little
bit about a game called h1z1 so h1z1 is
who it's got some history let's see it
was a survival game they also had a
battle royale mode battle royale mode
blew up and daybreak the developers
split this off into its own game and
then rebranded that as h1z1 the primary
game was previously called king of the
kill yes now it's just rebranded as h1z1
that sounds like a familiar story uh if
you think about fortnight which was a
survival construction shooter had a
battle royale mode that blew up and said
you know what that's actually the
primary reason people play this game so
so they made it a center focus yes and
h1z1 itself was an early access for like
a really long time and then mmm
yesterday it got a 1.0 release what
yesterday did yeah I was sleeping I had
no idea also like I can't is can can you
hear the game cuz a little bit you shoot
can you some foliot no I can't oh that's
right there's no sir no guns they're all
this is so yes
I just start right because I'm like is
it only cards fighting cars oh okay yeah
so okay
moving on to auto royale it's the mode
it's so h1z1 is fully out but the auto
royale mode itself is in beta just
because it's like brand-new so we might
see a little some hiccups some weird
things happening here but I was playing
it yesterday and it seemed fine
so what auto royale is as you'll see
soon is that four people are stuck in a
car and they can't get out but you shoot
out of the car to try and kill and
destroy everyone else but it's the same
battle royale style so you'll hunt
instead of dropping hundred people onto
an island you drop like 30 20 cars onto
an island you can't get out either and
one person drives three people are
trying to shoot out of it and the
drivers deal is that they have to pick
pick up like power-ups and other weapons
and keep it all alive and make sure you
don't crash into stuff so there's a lot
going on here sounds sounds exciting
yeah here we go we're not her shoot
because I was like for a minute I was
like wait is the audio completely off or
it's on okay alright here we go let's
get at so you come out of a cargo thing
and then now you gotta okay you can
shoot pieces give me that deep auto
right now lor it's the history of auto
royale it's I don't know much about the
history because I literally found out
about it last week yeah so what prompted
them do you think to all the sudden come
out with their game after they really
like miss the boat on that I don't know
I think that after a lot of iterations
you just kind of like say alright it's
in a good place to go and Plus that
Battle Royale wave is hot man and so is
this zone Oh Lord we got a pretty good
driver here okay that's good I thought
you were driving for a second and I was
almost gonna compliment you my license
expired did it really in real life
yeah I don't drive in San Francisco
that's
but doesn't mean I can I don't know how
to drive you know whatever helps you
sleep at night really oh snap my bad
okay so there's a driver and two and up
to four three people in the car who can
shoot other people huh got it so again
we got zones y'all were no circles when
it comes battle royale hot zone all that
good stuff
what and you can never leave the car
nope you think it out yeah it's kind of
a thing that we got going on here do you
run out of gas
7c yes oh that's interesting okay uh uh
actually I should probably say I don't
know because I I never really had to I
think that the whole there's fuel
pickups okay but I don't I haven't run
out of gas ever in this game because
maybe I haven't lasted long enough ever
to so we got some fools tailing us but
oh nice okay so there's pickups
scattered around the map mm-hmm
which kind of looks silly but it's
really fun light-hearted almost reminds
you it well it doesn't remind me of
twisted metal but with like four people
in there let me see what I got you home
repair kit
okay cool so yeah we also got some items
in here we got stuff in the trunk that
everyone can use
you got my own you start off with the
submachine gun and then you're supposed
to be able to pick up stuff all along
the map right so you can only pick up
weapons and drops basically or like
random spawns yeah oh I think we I think
we got one I think we're gonna get one
come on
yeah go how many people drop on the map
in the beginning is it 100 depends it's
up to 120 a nice cool well that's that's
a really good start I'd I'd say yeah
good job good job Michael thank you uh
that's that's all my team you know I
like to thank my mom my dad God is good
so you know stay up but we've got a
whole other match too oh the whole match
to go we have 40 people with 10 teams so
that's 10 more cards are out there I've
been around people seem really sad about
h1z1 they're like they're just talking a
lot of a lot of crap about h1z1 right
now amen if you think about it though
like for me h1z1 was the first battle
royale game that I like sunk a lot of
time and see like I played like the ARMA
mods
back in the day mm-hmm and they were
fine but they were like pretty janky
yeah I was oh gee operation flashpoint
player when I was younger so when battle
royale well when ARMA came I was excited
about that and then this battle royale
mode these mods cods pretty dope so I
got into that and then yeah when I was
like the first like full game that was
focused on battle royale that I played
and I played a lot with my friends when
I first actually moved to out here in
San Francisco so nice a lot of good
memories lots of bonding lots of like
friend friendship making yeah so I have
us I have a soft spot for h1z1 and my
battle royale heart mmm and you know
it's it was one of the early games you
know pubs you came along made things a
lot easier because the thing about h1z1
is that there's a few more systems at
play that aren't necessarily like fun to
deal with in in age in h1z1 yeah like
there's bleeding crafting at first when
I used to play the map you had to kind
Telegraph where you were at like it will
tell you what part of the grid you were
in but you never had like an icon that
says you're right here so you had to
kind of like oh the zone is between ìiî
ìiî
between 4 and g1 but I'm in g2 I need to
move here like yeah yeah you that's an
extra layer you had to think about
constantly right which I didn't mind I
thought that was actually cool like
orienteering yeah yeah you had to you
had to know where you were in the map at
all times to communicate that mm-hmm I
find that in pub G often times I think
that over time my map awareness has
improved dramatically in terms of like
my directional north what South East
West and using the compass to make calls
but I do play with people who haven't
played battle royale games before and
they're really bad giving like
directions or telling people telling
they're telling me or the other people
on the team like where they are yeah
it's always struggles like um right here
I'm looking they're behind the tree give
me some coordinates but I find that when
I play with people who have a strong
background in playing battle royale
games or these like survival based
shooters they're much better
or like Sims like they're much better at
describing everything on the map where
enemies are where they are where they're
going giving you know giving directions
and then when I play with people that
are new to it it's just always kind of
like a he's over there he's behind the
thing he's on yeah it comes with time
yeah yes but um taking all these med
kits bro
I'm not gonna front pub G was my first
it was for a lot of people mm-hmm no
shame in that
yeah I know it was a and I've been
addicted ever since so I feel almost
kind of bad that I never gotten on the
h1z1 thing when it was happening it was
like the thing that was like the hotness
on Twitch for a while to everybody was
streaming it and it didn't miss why it
was wildly popular but it I don't think
it reached the critical mass that
love G did I mean yeah so it's it was
impressive for its time though yeah it's
the handling of the cars still like
garbage on wheels it's not I don't know
if I'd say it's garbage on wheels it's
fairly similar to pub G and that like
it's it's not necessarily gonna be like
burnout paradise and it's also not like
Gran Turismo but it's no it's kind of
sticky and like also driving with a
keyboard and mouse isn't the most ideal
yeah yeah yeah for sure
yeah the control the thing though is
that when I was talking to daybreak
about how they changed the game for
autorai off they said that they made
objects easier to run through and run
over so you're not constantly getting
stuck because you know and these battle
royale games when you get in a car it's
easy to get stuck in alleyways get stuck
behind other objects so I think they
said that they always stand with uh
something nice to get him get him
to the first blow up yes the answer is
yes they shot a fire there's a lot of
home your car blew that's sad
six though good job thank you you got
lucky he was out of twenty with your
team the guy was a pretty decent driver
oh he was a really good driver so yeah
props of that dude who's playing with me
and I want to keep up with him again he
was a good sport you should talk to him
he was trying to talk to you guys in
there that's too bad wellis oh you know
be funny is if this audio that word
talking came through the game they're
like yo this fool just keeps running his
mouth who's he talking to
we just have all chat on they don't we
don't know at all pelipper says playing
with my ex army friends the best that
sounds like it's probably pretty pretty
intense in case just in case we were in
team chat just now yeah okay let's get
into another match let's do it how are
cute times at this mode are they very
like when I was playing last night and I
was being able to get matches like quite
quickly and they it didn't take long to
like get it started but this morning I
was having some trouble getting two
matches but that one that one didn't
take too long to get into cuz there's
like that downtime where they're trying
to queue up everyone get everyone
matched up mm-hmm
because you have to be in teams here too
you can't do solo you can't have partial
teams or I haven't ever been in a like a
partial team so I heard a rumor once and
I wasn't and I wanted to know what your
thoughts were that in the beginning of
pub G days early on they introduced a
lot of bots to the game to speed up
queue times so that and I never that's
just a rumor I read somewhere on very
reliable website reddit and I never I
don't know if it's true or not it was
just something that was like floating
around like yeah that's how those queue
times were so fast or in the early day
is because they just you know they
introduced a lot of can't say anything
about the zombies I have no I yeah I
have no idea either but
I was wondering if you ever heard of
something like that happening in other
games no I've really done it like I
don't I didn't think that you could
actually not legally but I mean I put
throwing BOTS without telling people
like oh this is a game with bots okay
that's that's that is out of my realm
this is not a sponsored stream just want
to clarify that yeah ours doing this
among our own volition yeah yeah yeah
there's there's nothing promoting us to
play this game I was in the fact that we
thought it was interesting its new game
inhalation zi1 yeah it's silly it's uh
whether or not you think it's fun that's
that's up to you to decide I mean some
people can play this to be like what the
hell I don't know ever plays again which
is you know yeah each their own there's
some funny moments in this game where
you flip it up over ramps and mm-hmm you
have your driver we're putting you in
very bad positions so you got a chance
play this for a week before it actually
launched no there was a there was like a
test period where if you wanted to you
could play dad like sessions hosted by
daybreak oh cool and they basically said
if you want to get in on this here's
some times that you can queue up and I
was able to get in for about half an
hour yeah I played that last week and
was like okay I see I see where this is
going
cool I didn't miss I didn't get to spend
enough time to make a decision on
whether or not I liked it because you
got to give time to games before you
come to a conclusion and I played a
little bit more yesterday and you know
it's not gonna rush home you're like
y'all gonna play that auto royale but
it's fun Oh Errol em says my cousin
actually works for daybreak games this
is so cool seeing this Oh awesome oh hey
what's up Errol
it's my boy he's from San Diego oh
really let's get it
I'm gonna San Diego this weekend Oh for
what yeah a lot of family oh snap
that's cool yeah I love it down there
it's a great place it's beautiful do you
know we're in San Diego uh yeah North
County mostly Oh North County I know I
know
North County is Buju
it is that's why though it's very nice
my mom used to the Point Loma Point Loma
school yeah there's nearly used to be a
militant Navy base yeah she slipped down
there
yeah here and then also Mission Beach my
dad lived on in the 70s lived on the
beach actually literally on the beach
really yeah
did he have like a house no no he was as
literal beach bum that's what's up yeah
yeah not hating
yeah no it's it's cool it was the 70s
that's what my dad anyway um well sorry
what do you say nothing I don't know
okay I was it's a you ever been to the
southeast no I haven't mmm South Beach
Paradise Hills one day skyline and
canceled that's where it's at I mean
well we're both well we're both in SC
together you take me on adventure yeah
sure
cool I'm down to show you uh show you
where it was good I'm about it it's all
Filipino food and the best thing the
queue and Mexican food
Wow finally a compliment damn this game
looks nice says TV mom oh wow your
positivity is appreciated today um a
little positivity goes a long way right
a lot of people are really mad this is a
funky day but oh look at this we got a
new spawn point look at this Oh am i
driving oh no all right the last game I
was I was a shooter now I'm driving so
this won't let you all know that we
driving out here come on y'all that
y'all need a wait you're driving now oh
great okay so we have some questions in
here earlier like hey how is the driving
in this game how do you feel the driving
is in this game right now it's quite
sticky
[Laughter]
yeah all right I'm gonna try my best to
help these people this is a lot of
pressure I didn't expect to feel this
much pressure while I was driving so I'm
driving now and I constantly have to
keep my eye on where we're going
so we have a safe place okay we're in it
that's fine oh we got it we got homies
or not holding hey you gonna pull up on
them I need I need to get more weapons
okay my my actual homies here so all
right so so this is like serious because
if you are not paying attention to the
pickups then you could make some really
bad decisions for your friends here yes
and you can you can hurt more than just
yourself got it got it your big
responsibility come on y'all y'all know
shoot out this box so I can pick it up I
stole all right James Chrome else's I
wonder what living on a beach is like
yeah my dad loved it he was talks about
a very family I imagine he didn't pay
much for ran I did have a car though so
there was that man and kls CSS I thought
h1z1 was Jed and oh yeah that was pretty
cool now yeah I think I think we're good
you know okay the reason people are
jumping back in is for this game mode
called Auto ryoute and auto Rio is that
the name of it yeah this will name the
name of the official name of the game
mode is auto Royale Auto Royale and they
also had their 1.0 release yesterday
many years later yes
many years later than people expected it
to happen come on I need y'all to start
pulling up on these fools oh my gosh my
dumb ass ain't even looking at the road
that's what you get it's like y'all I
have to say that the coordination in
here cheapies is lacking it was
definitely a step down from you got a
runaway you got a runaway this is not
good
all right peace out dawg hopefully that
truck just hits a tree look at that
weaving though hey y'all need to your
cars on fire
y'all you to put that vehicle oh my god
my teammates couldn't even pull up on a
okay
yeah the ARV so there's yeah there's two
vehicles
no you did not okay there's two vehicles
there is an ARV which is armored slower
but more armored and there's a sedan
which is a little faster more nimble but
in my experience right now it was not
that nimble yeah that's that was worse
match then last time but uh when you um
when you hit a low there's nowhere to go
but up you know I always say that's
myself but then sometimes it actually
does get lower that's sorry I mean we'll
see what happens with your game right
now yeah you guys at the bar real real
down there you know they could have not
shot any of their guns at all you know
at least at least they try it could have
been I could have had like three afks in
my car yeah that was great now I can't
even get someone to switch out oh man
that's so sad
Bob Jones hello welcome back to the
stream thank you by the way Bob I
recognize you from last week you in your
expert google searching we had so many
questions about medieval times airplane
Kingdom Come deliverance and this guy
came through with like all of the
knowledge from the medieval times
so it's resident best Googler tied a
badger to give it to you um how many he
wants know how many different weapons
are in this game mode in this game mode
there I don't know I haven't spent
enough time with it to find out but
there's you start with a submachine gun
I've seen a ARS ak's shotguns I don't
think their pistols because a pistol
would be a downgrade from an SMG because
we're trying to shoot out cars here I
don't know if there's any snipers but if
there are that would be incredibly
difficult to control
so there's also they introduced a light
machine gun with the 1.0 release so
that's supposed to be more powerful
obviously the light machine gun you'll
get a lot more bullets off faster you
won't have to reload as often but I
haven't picked that up yet but when I do
I will trip out because I need all the
help apparently we need all the help I
like how you said that so
calmly like when I pick that up I will
trip out yeah there's a lot going on in
my mind I got a lot on my mind
Carmen the YouTuber hello welcome
welcome and kls he said I didn't even
know they put still put effort into this
game yes just because most people stop
playing it doesn't and not I don't want
to say most a lot of people stop playing
doesn't mean that they weren't so still
working on it yeah okay we're gonna play
a platformer here so Keith Richards live
verse says what's difference between
autorai on battle royale or is just a
different name for it I think the main
difference is that you are in a car you
have to drive a car
so it's this basically the same as
Battle Royale it's just you and your
teammates are forced to be in a vehicle
but all the other rules that go along
with a battle royale game still apply
yes yeah the the basic premise is the
same you got teams up to up to 30 teams
a4 which means the 120 players total can
be matched up but the like in terms of
the map is the same but with ramps and
pickups and you know we got the zones
that shrink every saw ever so often and
got stay within them you got to survive
so yeah it's just a little little twist
on what you're used to and yeah or as
some people may think oh gimmick I kind
of think it's a gimmick I still feel
like it might be I will see how to play
your number if people really do love it
and jump in back in I'm curious maybe
I'll give it a shot with my friends I
don't know yeah you should give it a try
but I mean I don't even if you think
it's a gimmick that's fine yeah I'm will
still see you know I bet it actually is
this is this is my thing though because
I also felt that fortnight was what's
gimmicky I yes like construction was
like oh that's their thing that they're
well yeah that what that's not
necessarily what I thought because I
knew that the game had the tower defense
like PvE thing going on in in the
beginning before the battle royale mode
and right there hold there was like a
building yeah that was a save the world
save the world mode hoard hoard mode
combined with like minecraft yes so I I
knew that that's where the game started
so I knew that that wasn't like they
weren't trying to make their battle
royale have a weird gimmick thing that
was the building I just knew that it was
a function of game that they brought
into their battle royale mode because
why remove a function that's you can
already do in all the other modes yeah
so it's like the thing that was
fortnight for tonight to get it before
huh so I don't think that it's gimmicky
but I when I was coming into for a night
I was just like this is like battle
royale for children also what's going on
with your what's that live update is
that we are lagging pretty bad I mean
the I have you can see my pink counter
my pink counter says 78 milliseconds but
this I don't even know if I believe that
this is pretty bad it's super bad how
many frames is this well the frame rate
is fine
the whatever netcode or there oh pretty
man are we back no we're not oh I might
want to drop out it yeah this is
definitely one where I please I'm gonna
give it a couple more seconds to see if
it like picks up
but what's if that hits one minute and
it's not better I'm dipping okay
what oh so sorry go ahead okay yeah
generally that means the driver of the
car has 9,000 ping
oops said glitch much lol yeah this is
crazy
okay let's yeah guys that's not you
that's that's the server or something
going on here it's not you it's me
yes it's not you it's it's us you were
great
thank you we're just not this was just
wasn't meant to be this thing going on
right here um anyway when I was what I
was ranting on about was just that I'd
ended up playing for tonight with you
for the first time and I actually had a
lot of fun when I was playing
ah I we were dropping down I was like
tomato town what is this you know I was
like really very opposed to it yeah open
up your heart open up your mind I had a
good time the only thing that was hard
for me was that like late game meta that
they have gone with like the building in
the jumping in the building and the
jumping I just it's a lot to get your
head around yeah I was a little bit like
can everybody just like chill out chill
chill no I
I feel you because fortnight it's weird
because fortnight presents itself as
accessible and light-hearted
yeah and in many ways it is but and like
and you can you can live with that you
can just be like oh I'm just gonna do
pickups and maybe build a ramp so I can
get to like the second floor of the
building hmm and then things go from
zero to 100 real quick really quick like
the final ten in the game it is intense
it is so crazy
yeah I actually found it much more
difficult in pub G in the end to the
players that are really good at the meta
they've developed for the boy battle
royale mode that building like the
people who are really good at that or
I'm can't even touch him in the end end
game so yeah it's pretty cool so who
knows maybe this be a ton of fun and
I'll pick up h1z1 and
I will go from gimmick to oh my god this
is amazing yeah and also I saw earlier
in the chat somebody asked if we stream
every Thursday I I'm currently streaming
every Thursday Michael comes on so far
it's been like every other Thursday I
feel like it's whenever I'm needed yeah
when I will be there let's see yeah oh
hey just said in the chat as a reminder
that auto royale is in beta we said this
in the in the beginning but it's a good
thing to remind you that you know if you
see lag or cars like flipping out of
control like remember that this mode in
particular is in beta yeah don't be so
hard on the game because this is a beta
but if that if that were to happen in
the regular battle royale mode then
maybe though it's a bigger problem
because the regular battle royale mode
is officially out 1.0 auto royale itself
is still in beta the somebody here asked
what happens if you as a driver leave
the game to the other players and I
imagine they everybody would get dropped
out of the game no no no it'll it'll get
vacated and then you press ctrl-g oh and
somebody else can assume the role of
driver got it so you're not totally
beholden to the drivers is this game
still coming to ps4 last thing I heard
was that they in 2016 they put the
console versions on hiatus mm-hm and
nothing has happened since then so maybe
maybe something will happen now that
they have they have a 1.0 release for
the batter out mode so who knows yeah
all things are possible
but no word on that yeah fortnight
announced release shopping carts as
vehicles what's your opinion about
shopping carts I think are we being
trolled uh does somebody know what my
Steam name is or my gamertag that I've
used since I was a kid I'm driving now
or again my usual handle in all games
since I was like 12 or 13 has been a
shopping cart that is literally my name
really yeah that a shopping cart a your
shopping cart and you've been able to
get that on every everything you
sometimes the Oh is zero so who's the
other shopping cart the guy that I stole
the name from oh really
sometimes I have underscores sometimes
it's all one word but it's pretty funny
do we want to go down the road of me
telling the story of how I got that name
it's not that interesting but it's not
that long either I'm here for it I don't
know if they're for it but I'm here for
it so let's do it everyone watching has
to be here for it okay well as I as I
focus on driving here yeah make sure my
teammates don't die and they're
well-equipped I got it from playing Halo
2 on Xbox Live I saw a guy named oh snap
Wow light him up homie oh nice
oh they suck oh well then play each
other
oh I ain't having none of that
yeah they weren't either do a little
skirt screw what's your crown fire right
now
oh no that's them welding Oh in the car
they're fixing the party oh nice nice
nice
let's pick up some let's get some dope
pickups
okay be peaceful know what's up they
start shooting boxes before we run into
them so they kind of know James Cornwall
says first I heard of this game was when
they enhanced the ps4 version for ages I
thought it was going to be ps4 exclusive
what this game yeah no I mean it's on
some PC yeah but console release would
be dope mm-hmm I think there's there's
something to be spun to be had here the
I think I personally think that during
the right time of year console release
for this game could breathe in your life
back into it for people who were
interested in playing it like like you
James Cornwall who weren't interested in
playing on ps4 but it never happened and
who maybe don't play PC games yeah you
know but that that battle royale wave is
starting man you're starting to see
everyone do this is true
oops needs you to know to press shift to
drive faster oh yeah yeah okay I kind of
want to save that for when things get
real old wow that's a really small tree
though and we got a big-ass armored
vehicle yeah a tree told you no you
shall not pass oh god David wants to
know if this game is only PvP or does it
have a PvE the PvE mow or know the the
just survive mode is also its PvE and
PvP if I'm not mistaken I only played
very little of it because I was all
about the battery all stuff but yeah
there's well it's a separate game at
this point just survive is a separate
thing that launches in steam got it that
has zombies and base-building and other
things going on with it but Battle
Royale abilities
Ericka's people Thanks I like that those
tents randomly deflated as they went
from doing a very bad job yeah
well we did do worse yeah see arrow ass
wasn't pub she made because of h1z1 I
think there there might be some truth to
that
yeah it was a player unknown himself I
think yeah if I'm not mistaken he helped
make the h1z1 battle royale mode mm-hmm
yep she was a mod in the beginning sort
of or h1z1 was a mod at first and then
it flew out into its own thing that pub
GE was kind of his next project to kind
of like make a streamlined version of
what he had already made in the past I
think okay someone in the chat is uh
providing some clarification OOP says
the creator of pub G player unknown got
recruited by daybreak to create the
Battle Royale version of h1z1 from Jas
but didn't like the direction of the
game so he came out with his own game
okay
coming through boobs he nodded just
survived into the battle royale version
so much knowledge cool thank you very
thank you I always forget what comes
first the chicken or the egg yet me too
no one knows yeah I went I met player
unknown in real life once mr. green
himself right very nice guy cool would
y'all talk about hey what's up I was
like oh my god you're the guy you're the
guy you're the guy and he was like mr.
unknown he was putting cream in his
coffee and I was like oh I'm sorry to
interrupt you I do not but you know
are you mr. unknown yes are you mister
player unknown and I introduced myself
and told him that me and my boyfriend
and a couple that we know do we do
double date night how corny is that mmm
yeah
you told him that yeah I told him that
you probably looked at you like that's
cool I was like we spawn up it's a
double date thing you know it's really
you know I love it we're in a
long-distance relationship Oh
but that's you know and then he was just
like I love hearing stuff like that I'm
happy you guys enjoyed the game pub G is
Orwell battle royale in general it's
bringing people together that's cute
yeah it was really nice he was so nice
um it was really funny so this is just a
little little detail that I have to
include he was pouring cream in his
coffee at a station and this is it like
the twitch partners area at e3 and above
him was a poster of pubsey like what did
you put it there no it was just there
like they had decorated the lounge with
like posters of different games and so
he was like pouring coffee and like
fixing it for himself and like I looked
at him and I looked at the poster and I
looked at him and I was like mr. unknown
[Laughter]
like it's level marketing yeah doing it
was pretty good it's pretty good
Christopher Salas is hi how are you guys
in today we are doing quite well he's
you know he's been the driver for like
three games in a row now he's I'm okay
he's okay I never get too high I never
get too low mmm it's all good medium
medium well stop last night here in San
Francisco there was this there's like a
rainstorm going on I love it I would
accept that I had I have to walk like
from my bus stop suma yeah like ten
minutes I I have a 25 minute walk-in in
the rain also so so I took a shower last
night and voluntarily with all my
clothes
oh also you're heard of sunny San Diego
so you're not about that
yeah I think gloom yeah being in San
Diego's like oh it's raining yeah this
this never happened or this hardly ever
happened so this is dope out here it's
like I got I got I got stuff to do I
don't have time for this right now
NK LS as a battle royale aficionado
himself Michael Hein would agree that
with your sentiment which is since when
did battle royale get that cool
h1z1 release and BAM everyone wants to
play battle royale battle royale itself
is so old yeah it's it's not people were
sleeping on it yeah it's things just go
viral for some reason I mean I mean just
to pick up things go viral for whatever
reason you know it's that was I what
happens if he crashes into you at a high
velocity okay you'll take some damage
okay you're just like yeah I mean things
blow up for whatever reason it's I tend
to do as I've gotten older I kind of
shied away from like that that kind of
hipster mentality like oh I was I was
playing that way before
all y'all was and and if you feel like
that you know i I've come to also
understand why people feel that way and
it's mm-hmm something wrong with that
just kind of like I take a step back and
be like okay let me kind of think about
this a little harder you know I don't
like to hate anymore
no I'm not a hater I'm not driving
anymore so I can chill out a little bit
not have to worry about running into
things so Joya de Saron says I can't
wait to play Metal Gear where I'll
battle I think that's that really being
that's that's a trolling for sure if
Metal Gear I was imagine that like I was
thinking like yo Metal Gear survived
what if that had battle royale that's I
mean is that gonna be there saving grace
it was it was like is that gonna be like
their last their last poll to try to get
people to enjoy it again more or less
like that's kind of I mean I don't think
for tonight said all we need to save
ourselves let's do battle royale it's
kind of like Oh what if we did it to
look at it and maybe at least my
perception is that inadvertently it's
kind of like four-night is way more
popular than we could ever imagine
so maybe Metal Gear survive could go
down that route those Metal Gear RAY al
that's not bad alright
got something we got some action out
here it's not a bad idea
Oh homeboy pop some smoke screens hey
but I could see his health bar so at
least I know what to shoot at that seems
that seems weird yeah that seems like if
you throw a smoke screen down you should
not be able to see the health bar yeah
no that's what awesome oil slicks - oil
slicks wool yeah see were fishtailing
and stuff so some cool pickups in this
game that kind of throw it there were
some variables in there to keep things
interesting Wow bold bold statements Ben
says Konami would 200% do it - you think
I I mean Ben plays a lot of Metal Gear
so I'm gonna trust him on this one we'll
see Ben djenka and Tamar Hussein or -
Metal Gear survived people who played
put a ton of time to medal who survived
they would probably know better if that
game can be suited for it so max Keith's
ass on YouTube do you reckon this update
could bring people back to h1z1 I think
that's exactly why it happened and but I
could be wrong
I think they there was they probably
coincided with their 1.0 release to try
to get people excited about it to have
like a dual announcement right of course
yes that's that's what my feeling is
this is dude this is just me spitballing
ideas but I don't think Otto Royale
itself will like put h1z1 back into the
larger conversation mm-hmm I think it's
a nice treat for those who have been
playing and while I kind of mix it up
yes but I think that if this game wants
to kind of go back get back into that
battle royale conversation it'll be you
have not have to be on the merits of
like how good the 1.0 how people
perceive the quality of the 1.0 release
mmm so if it's impressive
yeah and so it's more or less the same
game at it it's had some since I played
it back in 2016 20 2017 it's had some
quality of quality of life improvements
but to what degree that'll help who
knows give it time I'm saying yes yes I
saw something in here earlier from Akari
and I had to bring this out cuz I
thought it was funny
she's a medieval medieval battle right
know where it's just bows and arrows and
swords and Kingdom Come Battle Royale
I could yeah King I could get behind
that I could but maybe not Kingdom Come
because it's too buggy and I don't want
I don't want a first-person medieval
battle oh maybe I do want a first-person
maybe go battle royale like it would
definitely be better in first-person and
third-person now that I think about it
like aiming down with arrows running you
know instead of cars there's horses
wandering around you know what'd be cool
about that is that so in a lot of these
battle royale games yeah see someone off
in the distance you're kinda like oh I
got to be careful but if you have a
medieval game maybe if you're super
accurate with your bow and arrow maybe
you can get them from a distance but
yeah if there's something like that what
if you look at them and be like alright
I see you why well throw hands or not
and they just kind of go up to them and
start fighting and you can run away and
you can probably watch people chase each
other around the map with swords and
stuff that would look really funny it
would be amazing would be hilarious yeah
you could have like horses scattered
around - like I said it's dead of
vehicles there's there's potential there
I am totally not concentrating on what's
happening
I'm sorry you got to do your teammates
right I mean not that we've had any
conflict since that yes you're right
outside the circle it's coming it's all
good right
so this match has been going on for a
little while cos we are able to get to
the point where we see the circle
closing in mm-hmm feeling feeling pretty
good about what we got there's gas
station points on the map I see that
yeah let me see it well make sure I'm a
quick wit so put some of that good good
though can you shoot as well what what
do you mean and you you can only drive
right yeah if you drive you can only
drive but you can stop other players if
you wanted to yes that's gone yes you
can switch on the fly okay cool
I think I'm just wrapped up quite well
Erol cave me in battle royale where you
just use sticks rocks and fire whoa
that's some next-level stuff nomad no
matter how I say we have like
mitochondria battle royale you like
place like little cells and you like
like that's that's we're going back in
time yeah we're going to the beginning
of cellular biology yeah I'm about it
God David SuperMario about Ohio I would
be about that that would be really fun
actually what would that what would that
be
I don't really know Yoshi's tongues
that's it each other yeah um that was a
good yeah yeah I played a lot of Yoshi's
Story when I was younger I love Yoshi
Yoshi she's okay you take that back
do you are his shoes are those removable
or those was he was Yoshi born with that
that's stupid that's those are obviously
shoes so he wasn't born with those
things on his feet absolutely nice
he's wearing shoes also this is the
saddle that saddle it's it's obviously a
saddle that's so dumb okay just don't
try to bring this into like it's Kirby
wearing shoes or those Kirby's feet
you know what that one's better than you
know she's clearly wearing sneakers okay
all right I'm not I'm not saying one way
or the other it's putting it out there
asking quick asking the real point
hard-hitting journalism yeah so what we
do here yeah Oh Kirby so pulled a pulled
a and h1z1 autorai all right we we had a
little scare there I kind of wish you
guys a good Loki me too that was pretty
funny was I say Oh Kirby so I saw this
picture of Kirby with a chin if y'all
seen Kirby with a chin it's now the
cutest thing I've ever seen it's so cute
I don't know what it is but it just like
that's why I'll look that up later
[Music]
yeah the ocean curvy are both awesome
they're okay
I had an n64 game side-scrolling Kirby
and 64 game that was dope I forgot
what's called but if you all remember it
that game was fire what about a Nintendo
battle royale like no no nope I'm going
off the rails coming back bring it back
bring it back to h1z1 h1z1 which the is
the game we're playing we're which is
the game we're playing right now I'm
Auto royale if you guys haven't played
again yeah if y'all just join us this is
the new h1z1 mode that's in beta called
Auto rail where you cannot get out of
the damn car stuck in a car yeah whether
you like it or not oh oh oh repair the
car that cars at 84 maybe we call
someone who's retiring if I think my
teammates are carrying hey that's good
yeah it's the story of my life
teammates carry me smash that's right so
James corn while riding my mind it was
like gonna go the long lines and Smash
Brothers Royale but where you have to
kick each other outside of a circle and
it takes very long yeah it would
probably have to turn into like a 3d
fighter it'd be crazy
Howard Stone battle Ralph you all want
to go back to the Dreamcast days maybe
that's something I don't know I'll sing
about persona battle royale let's get it
yahooza battle royale
let's get it yeah all my favorite games
Battle Royale
let's get it ah been yeah yuck is the
battery up my dude oh we got some copper
I need concentrate
you choose all the things all the Yakuza
Yakuza
yeah doc was uh excuse me I hear a
really weird leaking sound I know I hear
that to you
do we know what that is what's happening
to your car sometimes it's just got to
go we're actually absolutely deep in
this game so I kind of don't want to die
no absolutely no we are number seven
right now
Oh Lord lordy Lord whoa there's one yeah
these people are bug so what you see is
land mines you can pick up landmines and
drop them behind you almost like Mario
Kart yeah bananas can you repair the car
do we have a vehicle yeah we have
vehicle okay some of you say because the
last couple games your biggest fail was
not repairing the car enough and so it
just blew up
yeah we have so many repair kits that we
should probably stay on top of that and
I'm not helping
it's intense
Oh got star Thanks
you're so lucky you're a star but you
cry
I can see uses coat simulator better
I'll remember when that was the thing
goat simulator
I bought it buddy gonna live any messed
up I played a I am bread though that was
pretty dull I am bread was fun I
remember that that's cute my bread was
always dirty covered in lint hair all
the time that's what happens man
so circle is it's pretty smaller there's
only we have six we have six cars left
all right can you shoot the person in
front of you at all or no you just
technically shoot right through them I
hope so is it not and I would that have
been hurting my teammates and I without
you knowing it
miss coochie pull up my teammates are on
top of this
yo I'm where they're welding in the car
I know yeah nice repairing the car
Thank You Man esteemed this team I love
you all Oh big brother on story is big
brother thank you for coming to the
stream today sorry I didn't answer your
previous questions
oh boy well Michael is very distracted
I'll tell you my little gaming what made
me passionate about gaming story I
always screw up a game as my dad got me
a Super Nintendo when I was a kid and I
fell in love with it and was obsessed
ever since oh and yeah gaming was sort
of a happy accident I ended up free like
my first job was writing and freelancing
and I did a little bit of video on
camera a little bit of editing in that
that's how I started and it all just
went from there that's the super super
super tail of the GTR version what was
suppose your favorite nest game my
favorites nest game if she's Island uh
there's a lot though I loved that
console I really liked Buster bust loose
that was the Tiny Toons game that came
out for Super Nintendo and I'm not
familiar that's a great game
we got five cars left
sorry oh wow oh yeah
now these fools got a lot of armor got
some feelings and conversations
happening about EA and huh on Twitch
y'all can have that conversation yeah
well still five cars look how small the
circle is this is this is good each
other but we just come in saying and
they're attacking each other right now
oh my god we intercepted some intercept
at a chase
snap you're right oh why am i fumbling
I'm nervous
you got this okay cool going back up I'm
going back up in health because four
teams now yes if you can use another one
I would use another one I think my
teammates are bump it well busting those
outrun hey boss
oh my gosh we're stuck no stuck between
a rocket the cage the forever K turn man
it's hard oh my god y'all are seeing why
is the game oh it is wild right now glad
we're here yeah do you have any more of
those kids even use are you is the
health good health is good helps good we
have two more left
I should be punch P oh look at that
cards hopping around oh my gosh let's
use that use that kit my heart's beating
heart beating my hands my favorite part
of any battle royale the final moments
yeah okay it's got this me Nick we're
playing pub G last night we had that
final moment was like three teams and
duo's left and my heart was racing but
I'll still shooting I'm still getting
the house is like boom hand shot there
was a mine but it's all good we're out
of vehicle repair kits this is our last
stand
you're in a good position right now
they're busy another busy yeah I'm
really bad at this I'm running out of
ammo too at least for my rifles all
these fools are almost done let's go
nice nice nice nice nice nice two more
teams left good jobs
let's do it that sounds still freaks me
out but you got just gotta sometimes
just get nervous you know
yeah happens we're getting chased
getting chase this is 1v1 right here
y'all are witnessing someone v1 autorai
out for the for the win not good
I should probably deal myself
wait a mite knocked out I actually never
this never happened to me yeah
we're still closed we're so close yeah
they're flipped over come on let's go
let's go in space
this is scary you guys are so close Game
seven
winning three-point come on go yes good
job
yeah you got it that was awesome
witness greatness okay it was really
good that was fun in the end I liked
that that was cool okay see this is what
happens I have fun and then I take back
all the criticism mask I'm like okay
that was cool
I had fun I'm just watching oh man
options woo yeah thank you all for
witnessing greatness with me oh my god
it was it was good it was good perfect
at all h1z1 player here Michael hi own
difference you're alive huh when I won
for the stream those cool good job I
think we could do it again yeah
absolutely
yeah 100% let's go is that an FPS Doug
callback that was an FPS they'll call
back
man when I used to play CS source a lot
that was my boy I don't know if it holds
up today but I know I thought was funny
I'll give myself one it's this point for
telling you too you know he'll car oh
yeah
I mean honestly but this is as much of a
victory for me as it is for Sam over
here and so I just want to give a shout
out to um home girl Sam who's by
reminding you to heal yourself taxi
driver oh yeah yeah it's the difference
between winning and losing could be
someone saying like yo use your first
aid cake dumbass which is what I needed
I am I because I play a lot of support
characters and games yeah I know
instinct I always am reminding people to
do the things that are good for them
oh I tried to you anyway it's much
appreciated yeah I'm like you can kill
yourself zoom up please yes okay thank
you a lot going on you know sometimes
you just need a need a reminder yeah I'm
very excited about the new overwatch
character Bridget Bridget ah brigitta
yeah yeah yeah we were talking about it
yesterday and
is her name not Bridget it's not Bridget
not it's it's if you watch the the
character reveal trailer that yes lizard
put out yes she says her name oh and
everyone was like I did it everybody
think her name was Bridget well it's
probably spelled like someone it is yes
it is felt like Bridget so I I was like
did I just embarrass myself probably I
didn't know I watched the trailer by
didn't listen to it was sound on so that
makes that makes sense that's why I
wouldn't know it's Brigitta but I'm very
excited for her she's like an
amalgamation of a lot of my favorite
characters in games anybody who plays
League of Legends Leona
she's all about like the shield the
protector mm I don't know just a lot of
well I'm excited it looks good yeah
support defense it's always it's always
exciting to gamers
oh yeah saying hey are you gonna play us
do you think you're gonna play us her
absolutely yeah I'm definitely gonna
give her a shot okay
she is just a paladin for more crafter
Crusader from Diablo that's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that okay
wrong with that I love it I love this
like this is just battle royale with car
as well
yeah precisely it's all good so good oh
man I haven't played overwatch in a
while man David Ginsburg says is this
game free no it's 20 bucks on Steam
which is not too bad of a price huh
honestly yeah hmm yes yes I have +1 for
envel one gaming I recognize you I know
who you are
ok-ran Shubert that's Ryan yeah shell
out so Ryan Schubert I had no idea this
whole time it's a whole time I thought
that was not Ryan
it is my mind is blown oh the more you
know hi Ryan
sup bro oh did they stop working on the
ps4 port Clyde flexor flexor
- no uh as we know yes as far as we know
that is not happening who knows though
what they have in their back pocket you
have no idea that we like a couple weeks
ago I didn't know they had this Auto
rail mode so they may come out next week
you're like yo right well smells I
imagine I if I had to predict I'm gonna
say a lot more is gonna come out of h1z1
because they wouldn't like pick it up
again like this
they weren't gonna continue supporting
supporting it yeah so I would say it's
safe to assume that there will be more
h1z1 news who knows what it will be but
they were busted into another match here
we're short-handed we only have two
people we have a driver and me and one
other person shooting out the car so not
feeling too feeling too hot about
another victory here hello Georgie you
welcome to the stream welcome everybody
thank oh snap I should probably help out
trying to get items oil slick found in
the trunk oil slicks in the trunk Tron
Tron
whenever I see a tow truck on the
highway that has the ramp down with no
car on it because of all the video games
I play where you fly up ramps do that I
have this moment where I imagine in my
head that I'm driving a car it's not a
Prius and I fly up the ramp
I spin and I land like Vin Diesel yeah
yeah you think about it but you never do
it yeah oh you're just faking fronting
that's a cool thought yeah just driving
there's lots of thing about when I've
enjoyed driving a while but I kind of do
miss it you're just like cruise and
think about your life that's why you can
play this listen so I'm just like
listening to a podcast being spoken to
me live right now yeah it's all good
it's nice
but now you have Otto Royale yeah this
is this is dope I'm having fun I'm only
having fun because I won no there's okay
so are you one of those gamers that has
to win to have fun no not at all as I
hardly ever win and I have a lot of fun
oh my heart that's I'm not tripping
about it yeah it's like you know I just
kept putting bad since the way I think
that's what mostly is you know people
don't win all the time otherwise winning
would be can you run a root ten again
are you driving I'm not driving game
I have the animation for the 10 just
like collapsing and immediately was
pretty funny
whatever I kept I'd say oh let my home
and take it if he wants and we got now
for that Redemption you should try that
in a Prius dude a favor my Prius would
go from like no cool points to all the
cool points it would be the most badass
Prius on the road yeah but you know you
need to snap it or put on five it's
crappy fine fine yeah that was a thing I
feel like we started a lot of
conversations and didn't finish them do
you remember anything that we were
talking about that we got sidetracked
because we were actually concentrating
on the game
you know what no it's all gone I do
remember Oh my name is shopping cart oh
you know what I thought you were just
done with that story
no I so not done with that oh okay okay
so we're I remember we left off was
you're playing halo 2 and somebody else
had that name somebody else had that
name so halo 2 if you were driving a
warthog and you ran someone over it
would say whoever was ran over by
whoever the other person okay
so when I saw this other dude who ran me
over and at the time my name was
I don't remember my gamer name that's
not true totally remember it was just
really embarrassing oh look at his face
yep mm-hmm it's embarrassing it's I
would know I was 12 or 13 oh please uh I
need to know I'll tell you mine
when you were 12 or 13 yes no we're not
gonna go down oh come on
oh you can't that's such a tease oh well
all right
mine was I mean look I'm I'm doing it
anyway it was it bad was it bad it's
just stupid
so it was mine well you don't have to
share it though cuz I go [ __ ] oh come on
I just want to share in my god no no see
now but that's the whole point though I
was sharing it so you would tell us
yours too bad
dang I'm gonna do other people in the
office know it no it's that jerk of the
secret right it's not dark okay well I'm
gonna tell you guys mine now XO Sammy Jo
that's not bad
XO XO like executive officer XO like
that's like ghost hugs and kisses Oh
executive officer no hugs and kisses
because I thought I was real cute oh
yeah we can go down the route of talking
about old screen names from middle
school in high school because some some
of that shit's hilarious like when I
think it back to yeah I days like we was
we was all about this it's like
what I was gonna say so the reason you
took is because it was like rate you you
got run over by a shopping cart you know
that was really funny you're like I want
to be the shopping cart that runs people
over aha and it's stuck ever since
you've been a shopping cart
yeah if you some people thought you were
really good II hmm probably yeah when in
actuality I just like it there's so many
things you could have said you could
have been like was run over by a
motorcycle Hey okay run over by like you
know that's that's true that's true this
year my 13 year old dumb ass was like
died I was like oh that's yeah shopping
garna like you made this I made this yes
that's that's the origin story the
origin the story of the shopping cart we
have screen names back name it's all my
friends are like we're all like Filipino
and Asian and stuff so we had this
really funny like everybody's around
that everybody if you have everybody's
watching this if you have an
embarrassing gamertag please share it
I'm so about it but in the chat we're
going to curate these embarrassing
screen names and yeah not doing that
John May said my 13 your gamertag was
mr. Dumas arrow em I'll share my
embarrassing Xbox Live name it's not
that embarrassing little sure it's all
good
it was arrow wolf it was a combination
of Errol and werewolf that's kind of
cute that's funny yeah this reminds me
of my friend who oh my god his screen
name was like something paladin but it
was like a play on his name I can't
remember it I can remember it but mr. no
Bezos used to have me for president on
original Xbox I would I would love to
have you as president today here's what
I'll say so keep that name I'm enrolling
Bob Jones says this is 100% true when I
was in high school I broke my leg in a
shopping car accident how you gonna make
me feel bad like that man Wow
that's serious sorry I'm sorry mr. J
yeah man that's really I'm sorry that
actually happened to you you should feel
bad Michael man like I say is hope
you're alright man
stay sa mighty welcome to the jet thank
you for stopping by where this might be
our last match
we just won one it was awesome yeah man
if y'all if you're just tuning in now oh
man it's only two of you you're at a
severe disadvantage
sabirah to say the least I mean I don't
know how severe it is right no no he
just wanted he said I'm not driving
anymore oh okay
oh thanks for putting this are you
driving saw me yeah I'm driving now so
yeah this can happen in Auto Royale and
that you can swap seats with someone so
if you're the driver at first you don't
have to stay the driver forever that
might be some advantages
nah so scarves are yes you people still
play this beep yeah yes they do yes they
do and now there's the one point of
release and this Auto royale mode so I
imagine more people will be playing it
again yeah it's uh you know like I said
in the beginning of the stream
h1z1 has a special place in my heart
mm-hmm because the first not not the
first battle royale game that I played
but the first game the first battle
royale game that I put a lot of time
into with my friends back home in the
southeast so so it's a good time as one
been djenka says many times is that it's
a good time I thought I thought you were
gonna say like some something more
profound but just is that not profound
yeah I mean it's a good time it's a good
time it's like it's a good time I mean
these are funny lord of the Jeff left
waffle ultra Magnum Oh is everybody
everyone really sharing their yeah their
gamer tags when they were 13 yeah
oh I'm sorry I didn't I didn't mean to
uh it's your time
it was hockey Punk really yeah cuz I was
super into hockey and I grew up
listening to punk rock that's not that
bad I that's like I was if I was 13 I
would think that's cool okay what's cool
I'm not embarrassed anymore right yeah
hockey punk come on that's pretty good
I'm super in hockey I like I was like
expecting something real nerdy like like
like yeah those real like a last like I
don't know like something like really no
no a lot of screen names back in my day
was like XX age AZN pin oh boy oh yeah
six one nine yes yes that's all my right
my friend in middle school her screen
name was xx maganda xxx oh that's you
really fully yourself
maganda um please I know rich means
beautiful beautiful or it can mean like
good something or wonderful or it like
because you're the greeting is makan
dango maka which means good morning
beautiful or beautiful morning yes wow
you're really happy about your day yeah
sure why not
so some if y'all get me on stream I can
teach you some give you a some tagalog
lessons the wise old sage once said it's
a good time oh that's from mr.
philanthropy right yes
what are so the circle is starting to
close in there six cards left so you've
made it pretty far yeah there's been
like zero conflict so yeah and word in
the top wolf there's five vehicles now
so we're in the top five we don't know
crazy run-ins yet yeah and obviously I'm
just cruising mam's pickups like look at
home so here we go here soon let's get
em boys
there's three in there though so I don't
like our chances but now as our
topically they have one guy who's just
really bad yeah oh well that's the end
of that that foundation on that house
just had something to say about that
though them trailers is strong um okay
nice they're taking care of it yeah all
right I've got some I only have two
teammates but they're not they are aware
of our situation no real weight loss now
what really oh yeah yeah because I I
said that it was like I thought it was
gonna be something really nerdy
all right people real Legolas oh oh we
got oil slicks right here we're spinning
out of control we need to repair it when
that car went up the you oh yeah no
there are pairs are super super
important I'm sorry I wasn't there to
remind my deal wasn't I was thinking
about it I don't think I can you can't
repair yeah I can't hear ya I'm driving
but um it's not five didn't really get
much action but top five it's not five
right James Carlos those can tire get
popped I don't think so I haven't
experienced that so far because if they
did that would be a real pain in the ass
yeah yeah every time you're shooting do
we want to do one more yeah let's do it
let's do it let's do one more well I'm
having a good time yeah I hope you guys
are too unless the tape comes in here
and boots us but yeah we got time for on
today's a nice guy at least in my
experience
that was nice of you say I got I got I
always give myself way out of saying
something definitive so I know John May
I failed I failed sorry we all fail but
really it fell on your teammates to do
the car repair I mean you weren't in a
position to do such so I also only had
two teammates so I can't really put it
was a 3v4 yeah and which was not great I
don't know maybe we'll get better luck
at this time we have this will be our
last match whether we get 30th place or
if we get first place
this will be our last match
right yeah who believe well you guys be
in the chappy playing h1z1 autorai oh
yeah let us know what y'all think Yes No
maybe so it's also what games are you
guys playing right now like what's like
the hotness for you drop it drop it in
chat maybe I'm thinking me and Rob
played Kingdom Come last week it was
hilarious mostly because of how buggy it
was it does seem like a good game
I'd be down to play more that next week
if you guys are into come still pub G if
you're about that could use some of that
next week mmm puppies always uh we have
only hoped you together yeah I don't
think we haven't I've well I've watched
you play pub G on extra life yeah that
was really fun I was putting on Mike's
account yeah you were like psyche I'm
sitting on the floor yeah the keyboard
and mouse controls on the table so
you're like a little kid like yeah still
got like seventh place yeah it was a
solo match yeah that was really fun that
was that was I remember specifically in
that match I my car like rip either ran
out of gas or got pinned or the tires
got popped out anyway I got stuck next
to a building and I was shocked because
the guy was really my car was on fire
what if the only taken a couple shoot
like shots to make it explode and I
thought I got stuck in the car cuz of
the way it was pinned I remember that
and he didn't finish off the car so I
just jumped out and I was like oh okay
yeah that was a good game there's a good
one extra life is a lot of fun yeah we
had a good stream 72 hours and both of
those are the memories those are the
days some people are saying nope not
playing this game it's okay Boop says
they pretty much only play 21 Joe's or
fortnight solos interesting
Macari says I'm clinking them come and
night in the woods Wow night in the
woods
I suppose you got on switch maybe that
just came out on switch yes
the same IT nope I just came here for
gadget I don't even think catches in the
chat guys are you in there
oh no no grab gadget was and he just
went for lunch and he messaged me asked
me if I wanted lunch so I didn't say
anything and I'm actually really hungry
sorry yeah we'll try it alright P I'll
try and end this real quick no no no
it's okay
no I don't want any quick I wanted I
want to be number one again yeah we
gotta get to the end Michael you can't
match you got it no you need to like
change your attitude this happened last
time when we played fortnight you were
like I'm trash guess what happened i won
oh no not in fortnight now no well you
did get that one good game but that was
only after you believed in yourself I
didn't really believe myself when we
just won best man I was thinking I was
like saying oh I'm trash I forgot to
heal oh we're gonna die like I don't
even know if I have first-aid kids and
it happened anyway it happened anyway so
uh let's see some other traditions in
the chat for games he's playing John may
explain music siege
very good until what pub G or Xbox gets
patched Rainbow six is popping right now
yeah it really is
supernova is still rockin titanfall 2
wow you suck you've been sticking with
that game for quite some time
yeah lol PL 0 0 0 0 says play star
citizen I've actually never played star
citizen before robbers playing star
citizen the other day
ah Oh Chuck drive about it yeah maybe
that could be a thing
very ambitious game that is I'll say
that much Ben get out of here with your
monster hunter come on man that's why
you have Fridays yeah so if you guys
really want monster monster hunter
tomorrow yes your homeboy Ben Gingka and
John Luke will provide a good time
let's see halfway for hahaha accuser yup
Yakuza James Cornwall such a weeb who me
yeah hey I have a thing about
pronouncing other words correctly no
that's that's totally a thing that we
should be considered yeah consider it us
but I mean that doesn't change it so I
mean your love of its own is real I have
been you got excited when I said it you
pick guys all your spirits lift up
immediately whenever I hear the word
persona of my heart jumps yeah let's see
any other suggestions
Macari says she's gonna hollow knight on
switch that's a good one
max is you've been playing Fallout for
VR how's that that looks cool having the
papal eye on your heart yes that's so
cool that's really cool there's some
neat stuff in there but man 30 minutes
in P are done son this guy says uh this
looks like twisted metal coop oh yeah
that's I've always referred to this as
as like a twisted metal style thing
because I really like twisted metal back
in the day Oh needs to play it dosent
metal black is the best in the series
don't having you at him now call him out
do you how do you tell him how you feel
tell me how you really feel
i Keith Richards he's playing Rainbow
six and fortnight good choices
hot hot games right now I talked about
this before but I am playing Yakuza 2 on
ps2 that is the hot whoa
what is keep rolled and
yahooza - on ps2 yeah you have to pulled
out the ps2 whipped out the ps2 we got
Peter Brown brought in a very good CRT
TV thanks
we got component cables for ps2 I
ordered a memory card that came in
yesterday nice so I'm all set to play
yakuza 2 on ps2 because I don't have an
English version of kiwami - see I had
all those things that you just mentioned
oh man I could use ask you yep - the CRT
V I don't have a CR TV anymore oh you
can get them like super easy just go to
like thrift store secondhand shop what
they normally have them lurking around
so it's really good it's a good CRT V
and this is important
28 inch JVC CRT TV looks crispy it's got
that nice curved from back and it kind
of hurts my eyes though I'm not used to
looking at CRTs anyone who isn't a
couple people are excited about science
fall - still Gary Smith sustained fall -
is still the law of the land that's so I
can respect that
titanfall 2 is wild it's a good game
it's good time another great indie errol
says is Malaca
another great indie and it's based on an
indigenous culture and mythology that
sounds really interesting I love stuff
like that
and more and more Rainbow six siege that
makes sense sieges I really like siege
because it taps into the old
counter-strike itch that I had ever
since I started playing CS 1.5 back when
I was 12 or 11 stay mighty gage is
probably eating the most delicious
snacks right now and I'm pretty jealous
he do that's gadget is known for eating
delicious snacks and a lot of hot sauces
out
pop Jones I too have been doing this
thing where I go back and I play or
finished games in my library that I
haven't it's good habit yeah I recently
played Oreo in the blind forest yeah I
bought it I was extremely excited about
it when it came out and then I never
played it recently started playing that
beautiful looking game gorgeous and we
had somebody else ask about Daisy in
here I missed it cyborg man listen to me
I'm listening is dayz standalone still
early access I have no idea I'm sorry
can't help you
okay we're we're 11th place we haven't
had too much action but I'm also okay
wrapped up well yeah I get all the
things that you can get I'm take an 8k
for now but we don't have any aka ammo
which is kind of a problem why did he
just pass that I don't know maybe why is
he passing that why is he just driving
past the thing is to collect one of it
one of these dudes names has MLG Pro
like in his tag in his name is he's not
the driver because that ain't no MLG Pro
play come on yeah why would you just
pass drive right past by the thing mate
why would you not pick up all the things
that's my question
I don't know we got space in our trunk
I'm putting this on bro
I don't have any I'll have any ammo come
on hook us up
what's in the star steel roll cage wow
he just driven past that wait I'm
confused there a reason he's gliding
right by the no idea all night why am i
shooting at that he's not gonna pick
that up
maybe we got some ammo in here laminated
tactical body armor okay is that better
than five $5.99 I'm taking that oh did
we get em oh no we got
come on y'all ammo boop says the only
crates that really matter Lee are the
gold ones okay I guess that's good to
know mm-hmm if you really mean that yeah
this is again if you haven't if you
joined us in the middle of stream we're
playing h1z1 which got a 1.0 release the
other day and an auto royale mode and an
auto rail mode that is in beta
other than that laggy session that we
had earlier I'd say it's running pretty
well yeah I know we haven't had any
issues besides the one session which was
super lash super laggy like watching a
slideshow yeah but this right here like
we've had varying degrees of teammate
success which you know it happens it's
okay I'm not the best time I said Sam
he's just too MLG for us to understand I
don't understand those high-level pro
plays beyond me a lot of a lot of meta a
lot of things in there drive away it's
probably best to not engage cuz I ain't
got oh no oh yeah okay maybe he'll the
party look oh you have a tee it's okay
that could go down real quick yeah heal
the car I'll make myself useful
I got to be useful it's my team
it's not going well get the car again
yep see if I can stack these kits come
on we almost got it night it's nice
all right cool the peels yeah we need to
keep popping those though because who
knows what the ins car do you guys have
a lot of them definitely oh man yeah
this is Auto Royale in h1z1 this is uh
it's pretty cool I think it's a lot of
fun I'm having fun I'm not gonna sit
down and play this for ten hours
straight but if I want to take a break
from normal battery oh yeah
good change pace exactly okay we're at
100 we're good
I still need ammo do I have I still need
ammo for my a submachine guns been doing
fine for me the default weapon yes
and where there's nine cars left nine
teams and the circle is shrinking Chico
yeah okay
what besides the summer submachine gun
is there any other weapons that you like
in this game so far mode I've only
really used a K and M 4 or a are in this
mode so far and I think I really like a
R because it's single-shot but it's
really accurate and then if we got up
closer I'll just swap to a K and then
cuz that's fully auto so I like bouncing
between the two because that's the only
weapons I've ever used got it they're
shotguns in here but oh my goodness
don't ya don't know how useful we oh yes
wait err that's not for the 8k he's just
passing by literally all the green ones
all the agreements must be a reason
there has to be a reason I don't know
what it is it's driving me crazy
maybe you just want to fill up the
inventory cuz if every time he hits
until I don't yeah this but there's
probably a reason can't be too hard on
someone on people if we don't understand
their their situation
Macari asks if we are going to III I
don't we haven't confirmed any major
plans I don't know what the major III
plans are yet I know GameSpot always has
it at some presents at U 3 so it is to
be determined but people will be there I
didn't realize you can go in first
person in this mode but yeah these are
my friends these are your homies look at
this boy pull out a Molotov cocktail in
his lap oh man that's quite colorful
dope sweater man let's see oh it's cool
vest bucket hat Oh Mike okay we just ran
into a mine get on a first person that's
crazy
oh no hey what's up y'all I have no idea
that you're looking at them that's
alright we need to pay attention to the
objective which is to win you play to
win the game can someone mister nobody
asks can someone tell me the difference
between deathmatch and battle royale get
one life yeah one life and there's a
hundred people in a big field and you
have a lot of variables that play like
do I want to sneak around do I want to
be oppressive you only got one life to
live and if you can win among hundred
players it's a pretty good feeling
that's the a that's the basic attraction
of Federale modes yes John may one life
start no clip man cluck year 100 players
yeah and the ever shrinking zones
yeah really exciting it's like oh I have
to go there if you can't just camp out
the entire time you got to move
sometimes and the varying terrain I
think I said this in my review of up G
is that by default battle royale is like
each match stays fresh mmm because you
never know when the last battle will
take place yes so you play the same map
but that final battle is always
different keeps it fresh keeps it
exciting keeps it new
and just like in this mode we're
shrinking oh my goodness
what'd she do so there's six cards I
feel like there's a lot of cards left
for this
yeah we're and we're shrinking into a
busy city so it's all whoa weird she is
a nice little pirouette there yeah
whatta God golden the Olympics we throw
some lines out alright do we have things
of mine let's lay that down all right Oh
oh my god good thing it didn't do too
much damage but that really put us in on
this in a whirl oh it's like yeah watch
out
got office chase him down the ops I did
it Emma suck my heart I knew that was
gonna happen yeah I had a bad feeling
Susan put down like please let there not
be friendly fire for mines here we go
let's get it all both got oil slick we
I'm confused I thought you look car had
a pretty good amount of health at the
end there yeah I thought the two yeah I
was really watching that I was watching
that are those just bouncing around like
yeah it's like a little air castle
bouncy the physics that was pretty good
yeah that was our last match huh yeah
that was our last match guys thank you
so much for joining today on Thursday
stream I know a lot of people playing
h1z1 right now but we had to try out the
new mode and it was a good time and it
was fun we had a good time with it
I again I want to thank everybody for
participating in chat today and if you
come back tomorrow we do stream every
day Monday through Friday
not me tomorrow and not Michael but I
think Monster Hunter yes tomorrow
probably or something that could change
that's changed it's always pre-emptive
perhaps monster tomorrow and I will see
you guys next week on Thursday I had a
great time
yeah me too Michael a lot of fun always
pleasure thank you all thank you guys
let us know in the comments below it I
know this will be Avadh let us know in
the comments below what games you'd like
to see us play more of and I hope you
all have a wonderful day good bye bye
everybody
you
you